what's up [ __ ] gave our own YouTube
part 4 & 5 whatever we're playing we're
playing self-park everybody last episode
we uncovered a dark secret about kitty
cats I know it's exciting
let's slow to here and let's keep going
this fight was insane it was so fun
I love this game so much it's such a joy
to be playing it for you here on the
youtubes s race is where I am right now
I already forgotten what our quest was
it doesn't matter it doesn't matter we
could stills you could still have a good
temp
get into the background I wasn't there
[Music]
okay all I see I see we got to go in the
back back of cross so how do i stupid
kitty anything with a static defect can
be resetted oh wow we just got a hold
the fart
look it will go back in time and yes a
necessary game feature right there thank
you what and you let them hear you
stupid [ __ ] stupid [ __ ] do I look like
your mama oh these kids are cops ain't
no cop and he was born his mom farted
during labor and it gave him diabetes
that he uses to fight crime if they
aren't cops then we can shoot them along
with this [ __ ] too
y'all turning on me I knew I shouldn't
win in a business with y'all Tony
Soprano look at [ __ ] so long
cap no no net diabetes already nice that
is true actually
oh god he's gonna be stronger now red
wine drunk rainy hell yeah oh that's
awesome
okay so I do want to make some changes
actually as lame as lettuce
why is he long okay I want to adjust
myself because it's clearly not gonna
okay let's adjust a salad okay and let's
go oh my god
one-shot kill holy moly let's rewind
that one then apparently you can go back
in time with parts now oh yeah oh yeah
we can I wait ah what we can't use
anything here sorry what does he do
charging to fray Claus flying no that's
not the one hey [ __ ] take a note tell
my wife [ __ ] he can't attack what is
this
oh man she's super muddy a30 was
american number 31 America I'm sorry I
thought it was America oh my god okay
well we're we're blocking this nice
sugar rash all right cool
thank you
another one bites the dust
yeah man we did it that's what I'm
talking about and we got a new artifact
so jest that's awesome scramble class
[ __ ] start working two months ago
he'd be talking all this [ __ ] about
making money off the crime in the city
cuz some bigshot white boy be running
all the drugs now hook it right okay but
not me I'm my own piss you know what I'm
saying it's like I got one investment in
this world that's my [ __ ] and I ain't
putting no mortgage on that to some
high-paying [ __ ] talk about trying to
make no money off crime and [ __ ] classy
I'm sorry but what about the cash no net
cash okay that's this little asian freak
named yaki Baba some [ __ ] like yaki Bob
sixth grade is to take people's caste
[ __ ] up I think taking that [ __ ] and
like taking mine you know what I'm
saying that's like criminal [ __ ] where
do the cat go I can tell you but I ain't
saying it [ __ ] until I know I'm safe you
understand these [ __ ] ain't playing
and I need to know you gonna protect my
ass Eric Cartman do you have any idea
what time it is this is a school night
mom not now we're seriously onto
something you kids all get home now or
I'm calling your parents please don't
tell my mom and who is this stripper
woman these companies offer me
protection
well she's not staying here fine
Fastpass take her to your house okay he
took that thought fast boy no one cares
about me now what in the world good
morning South Park a new vigilante took
to the streets last night and is
apparently single-handedly takin down
the fam bony crime family here with more
is a [ __ ] in a bikini Tom I'm standing
outside the buca di faggocini where the
vigilante declared war on crime in South
Park okay young people's faces on their
balls it was just terrifying the kid
came in and just started farting on
people comes out of nowhere bad maybe
someone's finally standing up to what's
wrong with this city this new kids a
hero the kids a menace if you ask me
that's how long before he or she kills
an innocent person how long before
daredevil becomes the Punisher huh 3
season 3 season police called to the
scene found a treasure trove of illegal
items that they claimed might tie the
Italian restaurant to a larger crime
syndicate this may be just the tip of
the iceberg certainly chilling stuff and
their reports the vigilante possibly had
a sidekick
there was thought to be a sidekick Tom
but further investigation showed it was
just some little twerp with diabetes
thanks [ __ ] and of course the question
on everyone's minds now who is the
farting vigilante
that's right this is going to make us
look bad
you [ __ ] up it wasn't our fault this
kid just came into the restaurant and
started farting like there was no
tomorrow the pond is so games are
supposed to do is move the product the
Chinese and Russians do the rest
everything has to be discreet and quiet
or people are gonna learn the truth and
we put the product into people's drugs
and alcohol in order to create more
crime again oh my god and the cat is the
key to everything it's the cat piss
it's the cat piss again you just keep
doing your part in getting the cheese
out on the streets or maybe I'll start
dealing directly with the Russians or
the Chinese or the sixth-graders oh my
god
[Music]
oh man what a great sleep yeah I haven't
slept that well in weeks
hmm so you guys do anything interesting
last night oh no you know do usual just
watch some TV and went to bed
yep nothing exciting an art but boring
lives well then I guess I'll just be
seeing you guys tomorrow
you've got a big day ahead of you new
kid that's right changed into your
superhero costume and wait for a message
from the king who's the keen it's not
that different I think we need to work
on it that was dumb shut up shut your
mouth I don't need that from you any
good superhero should know how to
interrogate get over to Jimmy's house
and find out what she knows
King remember ah yeah okay go do Jimmy's
house can do definitely can do let's
lift this car for no reason hey how
about that we've got it faith the CD
[Laughter]
Cartman's good Christian Ben should I
kill these guys real quick cuz they've
been here for a while oh why what okay
they're all moving in [ __ ] is the worst
man I wish I could swap him out
we haven't seen Coons special attack oh
my god they're like choices
okay would be some more kids we're
grinding you don't need to say all this
this is just part of the game you gotta
do this okay well here we are finally
let's go
oh wow
sexy very nice sup hero don't be
fighting in my faces [ __ ] a Fastpass one
of your super homies is here oh hey new
kid the [ __ ] told me he wants you to
mention the witness so go ahead
[Music]
can I see your tattoo oh that's smart
using the silent treatment can really
make a witness and I look I know y'all
need my help is [ __ ] but I ain't talking
to you go get my medication your
medication yeah
I can't think straight without my
medication you gotta go pick up my
prescription on prescription oh my god
fine fine looks like you got more work
to do new kid but before you go back out
in the world I want to show you
something that might poke your
crime-fighting let's get up tonight so
fit whoa that was super fast mecha whoa
how did you yes yes of course
DNA PPA thank you I believe I'm standing
you need that okay
fabric am a little nervous in everyday
indeed before
oh we're okay we get here we'll make a
big impact on your comeback kind of like
how steroids shrink your bus or so every
all right now you know what real power
feels like pretty dang good
that's a do it you kid hope you have a
grasp of it now get out there and kick
some I I went with the tank I'll bleed
I'll be the tank class with this guy cuz
it give you a lot of it so hopefully I'm
a the right choice I don't know but we
did it it's fun to improve your
character and change it in step what now
what's next get powered up and leave
Jimmy's house alright well bye bye thank
you don't know what's next but I'm sure
it's not good oh yeah cuz we had to go
to the alley and get medicinal fried
chicken well how about that
South Park made the joke for me thank
you
I'm gonna go in here because it's always
so funny whenever you enter the
rhinoplasty I remember the first game is
such a weird thing
oh yeah cuz it's all oh my god got some
new items in stock new kid I know how
much you love medical supplies you do
know me we really don't have anything of
value hey we got another picture nice
that was a cute one let's make a deal
I'll follow you on Instagram if you take
a selfie with me how does that ha ha yes
okay yeah let's do that
wow thank you so glad I had a cool man
oh wow Oh Maggie defeat the racence
girls again more fighting fine you know
it fine oh there's so many of them and
he's dead I haven't failed a single time
god damn I'm good at this game
I'm so good I'm born to do this no I am
I know
oh no not Rebecca oh my god oh my god
Rebecca Oh Oh Rebecca oh my god I'm not
ready for this
[Music]
the wrong raisins sugar oh my god people
just like the picture of me and ballet
class on Instagram what's holy getting
trolled right now the true horror over
Millennials oh my god it's raining i'm
unfriending their instagrams explanation
they will be back for a while you got to
be careful playing superhero you can
make a lot of enemies
some bullies think girls don't make good
superheroes not me
if that respect don't be excluded don't
you is that why your parents are hiding
you because your gender doesn't fit in
with the norm you'd like to remain
mysterious huh fine look you've got
problems new kid whatever you did last
night got a lot of people's attention
bad people there's a crime boss who's
been calling the shots here in South
Park and now that person is planning to
run for office whatever you did last
night scared him I'm tracking everyone's
instagrams and Facebook's and will
continue to cross-reference with tumblr
while monitoring Twitter and LinkedIn if
you need information just know you can
rely on a call girl oh my god Carl girl
that's me
I'll thank God we didn't have to fight
her Becca I was like what how got damn
soiled myself a little bit there boy all
right we can keep going in great
well proceed to the medicinal fried
chicken chicken winners
[Music]
well how the heck am I gonna do this
too bad new kid miners aren't allowed in
a place like that Gordon Freeman please
help me what do I keep calling you
Gordon Freeman of course you aren't just
any miner
of course I can change time what in the
world is happening over here
[Music]
by super-spicy city shrimp find skeeters
roof aged cheese
what okay a member berries maybe I
remember that too old for me
here we are shitty walk let's sound like
the fast pot got damn fast pass I have
the one run so far
gosh damn it alright let's enter I'm
excited for this super spicy shitty
shrimp we can buy a new outfit it's not
that cool well save our money super
Spidey spicy no no no that was it fine
and then find cheesy shrimp adders okay
okay we're doing right find skeeters
roof aged cheese everybody okay okay
okay I think it's every year yes yeah
well I'm working on e roof
aged cheese how the heck am I gonna find
a
remember when Superman movies weren't so
depressing oh I don't take kindly to
selfies gotta take those selfies man
great see you later kid
Skeeter who's Skeeter again I feel like
this would be easier fine now kid I'm
trying to pick up chicks and maybe I
need to keep walking want some of this
boardy I guess so
[Music]
you need to unlock in your body power to
solve this meet human kite at Kylie's
house we have to do a side quest first
Bosh okay over here it was really funny
last time we did this I really want to
change my outfit later I have a lot of
money now okay what's happening what is
he doing what is he a backyard in the
backyard okay right okay let's take care
to this where kaizen kayo I have
developed these super sensors which will
make it almost impossible for him to be
deceptive oh no he's actually gonna be
strong now are you kidding me fine the
Red Sea which you will be unable to part
without Moses on your side so we have to
go over that's annoying
we can't attack them there god damn
let's remove that one we don't really
have a charging attack with this one
this one can charge to captain diabetes
[Music]
diabeetus tan that was really easy we're
really strong now unless it's the second
phase or something yeah there's the
second phase oh no oh no oh so much step
[Laughter]
don't worry super buddy cousin perhaps I
no longer have my kite but I still have
[Music]
why we're gonna find out and what Dad
kind of innovative the baby is that
little bad ginger tea ban nice
oh she attacks everyone damn
my mom's a bigot [ __ ] no one will love
the music so good hey not this one not
this one
[Music]
[Applause]
hey we got a new artifact nice okay we
did it I enjoyed that very much no no
mom no police this is all my fault
what look it's just I couldn't take my
cousin copying everything I do the human
kite is about saving people not about
Judaism and now look at all the damage
you've caused I should press charges
against your friends and luck my kites
up in a tree I'm sorry please I'll do
anything you are going to let your
customers is that clear oh boy hi Regina
says I get to play with ya yes sometimes
you can play with us
you're not playing anymore until you do
come on sugar let's get you some bactine
oh I hate bad King because it gets on my
fingers and I get eczema from the
lidocaine oh really that doesn't work oh
yeah we have to learn his new ability
which makes him fly yes invalid buddy
what I hold l2 and highlight peanut well
that's what I did oh I see we have to
pick sky okay okay so green objects
captain diabetes can do and then those
wind looking Kyle Kyle can do that makes
sense
hey maybe close your eyes I don't know
that my god okay so you have to actually
do it properly
I was paying attention really hardcore
everyone hardcore incredible Wow
this gave me some weird how did we get
damn for me alright that works
that was babies oh I got news for you
buddy I'm sorry but we're gonna have to
fart cooler than you've ever felt before
and need you care now this may sting a
little bubby oh my god he's so annoying
guys my bad
[Music]
why is the door locked I have to do
something now
all right I forgot we had to return this
to be kind
jeans degree all right we're gonna fast
travel all the way okay so now that we
have Kyle we can get on the roof right
or do I use it on this thing yes there
we go nice that's a cool thing I get it
now I was I thought it was so weird
before I'm texting Kyle yeah boy
yeah Cacambo man that's some top-level
farting okay let's okay let's do a [ __ ]
stir Graham thank you thank you
Simon Thank You Simon have we dumb ones
with Kyle and there's a cheese crap did
just like I taught you
crafted grab like I tell each what in
the world to the missionary a cheesy
shrimp fairytale of course of course
I accidentally sold I was pretty good
crap that kay let's head on down that is
a great question
see you buddy okay and now we can enter
Gordon Freeman because that is his name
there we go now we can enter yes obscure
to go on we don't go on don't be shy
oh thank you press X to eat the cheese
see stream perrito what's gonna happen
are we gonna shrink volition burrito
perhaps time for pause unlock oh my god
I just
I didn't work out the way I wanted it to
we paused
maybe we should pause before now we can
buy our medicinal chicken please after
you
okay we're gonna have to no actually I
can't save so I'm gonna keep playing Oh
is your friend looking for an energizing
mental feeling or a more of a full-body
hi I don't know well I'll send over our
expert budtender who can help you out
yes I have an addictive personality so
I'm cool without it now I got a kid with
my better to stay on the strip but I'm
also doing good helping people find the
herbal remedies they need combat modern
stressors of a job and taxis traffic and
white written down my neck okay her name
is classy classy with a wire with the
clip hanging off it coming around and
look at the [ __ ] out of oh my gosh with
a dick hanging off the eye that's [ __ ]
2l out of the SS oh that classy sure I
got her order
no it is not nothing cool I'm trying to
run a legitimate business here and my
back hurts I can't sleep I got no
appetite the shitty town is so [ __ ] up
we gotta buy all our product from
[ __ ] sixth-graders and who knows what
the [ __ ] they're putting in it [ __ ] top
it off I got a couple little dick
liquors covered in the past door oh it's
another fine sober Towelie I really have
to end this episode here thank you guys
for watching another one the best let's
play on YouTube the leave a like leave a
comment and leave a subscribe blefuscia
bye
yes see you tomorrow